would you like to see taking over from
Liz Trust
well I have no View at all on who the
conservative party should choose as
their leader but I do believe but the
conservative party is ungovernable and
whoever is selected will simply find
that there will be new factions inside
the party more determined to do than
done than any other political purpose
they will have
Britain deserves better than this we all
deserve better than this which is why
clearstana is absolutely right but the
only way to have a fresh start that we
need is to have a general election as I
hope a labor government has a result
but how are you going to get that
general election the Tories don't seem
in the mood to go to the country now
well I think they what their Authority
is completely collapsed and I think that
whoever they elect as their next window
will simply have on their hands exactly
the same problem as their more recent
leaders have had but if you can appeal
to one part of a conservative party that
guarantees
towards you from other factions within
the same party they no longer fit or
able to govern they should recognize
that they surely are people in the
conservative party who believe that the
interests of the country are more
important than the short-term interest
of their own party
they should put their case to the
country and let's see who wins
but I'm just confused as you how you're
going to bring about this election if
the conservatives are set against Going
to the Country how do you and labor the
SMP how do you bring about the lib Dems
how do you bring about this election you
also want so clearly
well you're you're right of course
opposition parties do not have the votes
on their own to see an end uh to this
Parliament a parliament whose course has
run and has created enormous damage in
the lives of people in Wales and to the
reputation of the United Kingdom abroad
I simply think that we cannot we simply
cannot go on with a series of
traumas inside the conservative party
creating the damage in the lives of
other people they should recognize that
if they're confident in their case
tickets to the country in an election
and let's see but there is a new
government with a fresh mandate and an
opportunity therefore to deal with the
enormous problems that lie ahead of
whoever is in government
and what about this growing suggestion
uh Mr Drakeford that Boris Johnson could
uh stand in this leadership contest
well that will be for the conservative
party to decide uh it's only a matter of
months ago but nearly 16 ministers in Mr
Johnson's last government decided that
he could not be trusted to tell the
troops to such an extent that they
weren't prepared to serve under him does
anybody believe but all that has simply
gone away in a few short months
uh but someone was making the argument a
little earlier that at least Boris
Johnson could argue in a way that he has
a mandate
well when he had a mandate that Heath
returns a wedding and uh you know he
destroyed Amanda mandate he had because
of his own conduct in office and because
he's not out of the woods even on that
point because there is a House of
Commons inquiry into whether he failed
to tell the truth to the House of
Commons uh anybody who thinks to the
return to Boris Johnson is somehow a get
out the jail card for the conservative
party must have some of the shortest
memories in political history